نذهب الان الى بروكسل مراسل الجزيره عياش
دراجي من هناك يتابع لنا مظاهره كبيره
تنظمها جمعيات داعمه لفلسطين ما الذي
ترصده لنا
عياش جمعيات كثيره ومتظاهرون كثر خرجوا
اليوم في بروكسل للتنديد بما يسمونه اباده
بشريه اباده جماعيه تقوم بها او يقوم بها
جيش الاحتلال في غزه بلا هواد منذ اكثر من
70 يوما الصوت هنا في في العاصمه
الاوروبيه اكثر جراه منه في كثير من
العواصم الاوروبيه الاخرى العالم
الفلسطيني يرفرف الكوفيه الفلسطينيه يعتمر
الكثيرون هنا يقولون في اكثر من شعار ان
ان قتل الاطفال والنساء ليس دفاعا عن
النفس ابدا ويطالبون بوقف هذه الحرب
العدوانيه ويطالبون بضروره ان يتدخل
المجتمع الدولي لوقف هذه الحرب التي اي
تاكل الاخضر واليابس في
القطاع المعتد عليه منذ 70 يوما ايضا
كثيرون هنا ينددون بالصمت الدولي بال بما
تفعله اسرائيل من عدوان بلا رقيب او حسيب
ويتسائلون الى متى يستمر هذا السكوت الذي
يتسم به المجتمع الدولي وتبقى قراراته
حبرا على ورقه المتظاهرون انطلقوا قبل نحو
نصف ساعه وتستمر المظاهره لاكثر من ثلاث
ساعات هنا في
بروكسل شكرا جزيلا لك سنبقى دائما في
المتابعات نعم ونحن نتابع صور عديده
لمظاهرات عياش دراجي من مختلف المدن
والعواصم وهذه صور من برلين في خروج ل
سيارات تحمل الاعلام وترفع الاعلام
الفلسطينيه تنديدا بالحرب الاسرائيليه على
قطاع غزه اذا مظاهره ك
نبعها ال بالسيارات في برلين بالمانيا
نشكر عياش دراجه كان معنا من
بروكسل